time for some gears of for news now as
producer rod Ferguson has claimed that
the game will be a graphical showcase
for the Xbox one I'm Lucy and welcome to
this active reload gamespot news update
speaking to official Xbox Magazine
Ferguson says that developer the
coalition's work on Gears of War
Ultimate Edition is shaping how the
studio is approaching Gears of War for
with regards to visuals delivering with
Ultimate Edition the first 60 frames per
second multiplayer experience in
franchise history really taught us a lot
about what it means to have a 60
frames-per-second culture on the team
and we're leveraging that experience for
Gears of War for as Ferguson pointed out
achieving 60 frames per second on Xbox
one was not only possible for the gears
of war Ultimate Edition but also for
halo 5 Guardians that producer who
worked on the original gears of war and
Epic Games said he sees history
repeating itself with regards to gears
of wars graphical quality as the
franchise moves to new hardware like how
the original Gears of War was a visual
showcase for the xbox 360 Gears of War
for will be a graphical showcase for the
xbox one ps4 is due out sometime this
fall a beta will be held prior to launch
with those who purchased early copies of
Gears of War Ultimate Edition guaranteed
to get in so does frame rate really make
us the game let me know in the comments
below I'll come find me on Twitter I'm
at Lucy James games for all the latest
on Gears of War for keep it gamespot